there's quite a lot of military activity
actually because the Russians found that
they were severely disadvantaged in the
Black Sea when they lost the mosque for
the flagship that went down on the 14th
of April and with that they lost most of
their air defense in the Black Sea and
since then they've been trying to do
something about it one thing is that
they've had their ships have been pushed
away from Odessa because the ukrainians
have been given missiles Harpoon
missiles and apparently Brimstone
British anti-ship missiles which are
keeping the Russian ships at least 100
kilometers offshore because they then go
any nearer and meanwhile there's been
quite a battle going on at Snake Island
Snake Island which has been in the news
on and off since the very first day of
the war and the Russians have been
trying to put anti-aircraft defenses on
Snake Island in order to compensate for
the loss of the mosquefa and failing
three or four times as the ukrainians
kept attacking them every time they
tried to put something on there but it
looks as if after a series of quite
Fierce small battles a real war within a
war it looks as if the Russians have got
some surfaced wear missiles there now
the SA a15s and sa21s 22s rather seem to
be now on snake island and they've given
themselves some uh air defense in
addition
um Russian Corvettes have been seen now
with sa-15s strapped onto the back of
them literally strapped onto the deck as
an sa-15 as surface to a missile
land-based system operating at Sea won't
operate all that efficiently but it'll
be better than nothing so the Russians
are giving themselves some capability
now to actually move further in and
tighten the blockade of Odessa which has
been going now since the early phase of
the war